all right um welcome to Howie Mandel
does stuff we didn't start yet this is
kind of a cold opening we don't do it
it's an apology and it's an apology to
Ethan Klein and the H3 podcast
um I'm a fan Ethan you know I love you
and I love everybody there I saw
this clip
dude listen to this
Jimmy
hits me up
and says do you want Carrot Top on your
show
and he sends me a picture of him with
Carrot Top and I'm thinking there's no
damn way he can get me Carrot Top not
that I think that Carrot Top is like a
super hard Gat I mean peace and love I
like Carrot Top
I like him I always laugh when I see his
bits man
but I'm like Jimmy doesn't he can't get
me anybody right so I said yes Jimmy I
want Carrot Top just to see if he could
do it he sent us a number
so you should know that I have a history
with uh caratop I actually called him he
is doing he's on this episode I did not
take the idea from you number one and
number two I apologize for not going
through through Jimmy we just got him
ourselves I'm actually surprised you
didn't go through Jimmy
but next time for our next guest so we
apologize to uh Jimmy Lee the Jersey
Outlaw and uh mostly to Ethan I'm sorry
subscribe like
here's the podcast
there we go there we go now it's
official it is this is Howie Mandel does
stuff I'm Howie Mandel I'm Jacqueline
Schultz his daughter
oh my God I can't believe this I feel
like I'm in timeout over here in the
corner really yeah I'm in the corner
about myself it's okay how are you